foreign
Jesse hey good how you doing Mr Ken Mr
John thank you so much for the
opportunity to talk to you guys you bet
what's up
well um real quick try to give you some
context
um my life is a bit complex as as much
as I'm sure as everyone else but
basically the specific that I wanted to
focus on is I currently have I work two
jobs right now but one of my jobs I work
with a family member I'd rather not
disclose too much about it but basically
work with family member for the last
couple of years now
um I honestly entered this world of
construction I work with him in
construction
I'm not knowing a dime not knowing
anything basically kind of lost
um I entered it because I my my I guess
my place of work has been more creative
realm as far as making videos and all
that kind of stuff but I found myself in
Cove at times when there was no work
obviously at that time so an opportunity
came up to work and you know I need we
needed needed to get the money at that
time so I took the opportunity to work
with with a family member and
um basically just jumped in not knowing
a single thing
um and there was an in construction like
I said and kind of been in there for the
last couple years last three years now
and to be quite honest with you I I
don't know how to move around the
situation in itself I sometimes do feel
a little lost as personally what I
really want to be doing and I know you
have written a couple books about that
but kind of going around the situation
um is you know right now because
construction can be so volatile as far
as you know things going up and down and
prices here and there also management
wise how things are managed affect that
a lot of people are working companies so
let's let's dive in real quick Jesse
what what is the situation you've
referred to it but what does that mean
so in detail it basically means that I
I guess I will disclose it in a way that
I left my father-in-law I worked with he
has a small company Construction Company
and it has been going okay he's been
trying to manage it the best as he can
um and so getting these projects and
getting all this uh work kind of
situated payments have been really slow
and so
um does that mean payment to the company
or payment to you
both okay so whatever whatever happens
with um the outside we don't get paid by
Cup by uh clients money is not flowing
through Jesse is it safe to say Jesse is
it safe to say that you're pretty
frustrated but you feel like you might
be trapped because this is your
father-in-law
that's probably yes that's most likely
how you could describe it okay so the
way you set that up earlier and I want
John to jump in on this because this has
got some really really unique family and
relationship Dynamics but
um you said I need to figure out how to
navigate or move around I don't I don't
know that this is a move around
situation I I think this is probably
going to end up being a move on
situation and you're gonna and John's
gonna give you some pretty good advice
here on how to do that but I and the
reason I'm saying that and I'm asking
this and then I want John to jump in but
but if if I guaranteed you today
a clean break
meaning no stress no whatever just clean
break no consequences you walk
father-in-law's great life's great
whatever would you walk today
uh yeah honestly yeah the only
hesitation I'd have is I don't know
where to go to next well we'll worry
about that that's secondary and I'll
help you with that but I want John I
don't have anything to add oh you've
you've said it yourself Jesse it's time
to go yeah and I think you need to make
peace with that
um don't avoid the hard conversation
you're at a job you're not getting paid
man if this is any other boss
you would have already been raised in
hell you work hard you don't get any
money or the jobs are sporadic you get a
random email or random phone call or
random text message hey tomorrow be so
and so at 6am you can't live like that
you gotta have steady work to take care
of your family and support your family
deep down your father-in-law knows that
too so it's time to go I think it's a
matter of figuring out what's next is
your wife sure she's on board with this
too
yeah she's been great um and a bit of
context this is where I would like to
say it's complicated it may be not be
that complicated but
um because it's my father-in-law she
they decided to put her under as the
main owner of the company this was
before we got married
she did so to help his obviously to help
him out
um and kind of put him in a better I
don't know I don't know the real reason
other than her she's the primary owner
of the company
yes sir is she the primary owner but
he's like he makes all the decisions
he's the shareholder
yeah sure so does that mean that she's
paying taxes on this and he's not
um but yeah it's actually a I think it's
an LLC right now does she take any sort
of disbursement does she get paid at all
on the back end of this deal
supposed to but it hasn't been any
um it hasn't been there hasn't been any
any process so here's my concern she you
and her are carrying 100 of the
liability with absolutely no payout the
only reason you sign up for something
like this it's not Criminal
is you want to the benefit of the bottom
line payout which is awesome that's why
CEOs take the risk because they make all
the money if something goes sideways
they're they have insurance and
liability for for what happens you all
have all risk all risk
it sounds very eerily similar to parents
who take out credit cards in their kids
names
I honestly with you guys I have known
that for a while and you know and to be
kind of strength with you guys my you
know I trust in God and I I've gotten
Council before and I hear that too and
but the thing is you know that that
relational part I'm like I don't know
what to do so here's the deal brother
here's the deal if we're against it
either no no no no father-in-law already
burned the relationship you're still
holding on to the end of it
you didn't do this as the great saying
goes not by your hand but in your lap
your father-in-law chose to set himself
up in a better position at the expense
of his daughter and her family
and then brought you along and says
you're one of us now you're one of us
I'm not gonna pay you
or except sporadically I'm not going to
give you work except sporadically
and he's just keeping you hanging on and
hanging on and hanging on if this is my
house I would sit down with my wife and
I would strongly recommend we get out of
the partnership I don't want to be an
owner here and if it's an ownership
thing I'm gonna go sell my business to
somebody or I'll sign the deed over and
y'all can deal with it and you brother
go find another job
yeah I I agree I would just tell you
right now go get a job doing what you're
currently doing let's let's not worry
about what my future path is right now
I'm going to give you a couple of tools
that will help you with that but right
now it's like if I can do this and I'm
doing it for my father-in-law who's not
paying me first step is I want to I need
to get some stability and deal with that
financial piece first so that I go work
and I just gonna go get a job getting
paid doing something I know how to do
then we clean this mess up maybe we need
to get some legal counsel on unraveling
this deal just maybe get a consultant
like let's get a lawyer on this and
let's figure this thing out
um but we need to have a hard
conversation with the father-in-law as
well as John said uh I'd unravel this
deal and then let's figure out what your
future looks like to that end uh hang on
the line uh Austin's going to get you a
copy of uh actually an assessment code
the get clear assessment it'll help you
with Direction the book from paycheck to
purpose will help you with next steps
but as John said hard conversation
tonight you and your wife need to decide
what it is we're doing and inform the
father-in-law getting with an attorney
would be really wise just to look at the
structure of this Arrangement yeah
don't talk to father-in-law until you
all have your decision made and a path
forward and then you're going to let
them know what you're doing